they are not dead who live in the hearts
they leave
[Music]
behind all plants are our brothers and
sisters they talk to us and if we listen
we can hear
them day and night cannot dwell
together it is better to have less
Thunder in the mouth and more lightning
in the
[Music]
hand tell me and I'll forget show me and
I may not remember involve me and I'll
understand before eating always take
time to thank the
food
don't be afraid to cry it will free your
mind of sorrowful
[Music]
thoughts when we show our respect for
other living things they respond with
respect for
us if we wonder often the gift of
knowledge will
come most of us do not look as handsome
to others as we do to ourselves
[Music]
those who lie down with dogs get up with
fleas in age talk in childhood
tears we always return to our first
loves when you were born you cried and
the world rejoiced live your life so so
that when you die the world cries and
you
rejoice those who have one foot in the
canoe and one foot in the boat are going
to fall into the
river the weakness of the enemy makes
our
[Music]
strength a good soldier is a poor
Scout poverty is a noose that strangles
humility and breeds disrespect for God
and
[Music]
man we will be known Forever by the
tracks we
[Music]
leave do not judge your neighbor Until
You Walk Two Moons in his
moccasins there is nothing as eloquent
as a rattlesnake's
tail
Force no matter how concealed begets
resistance our first teacher is our own
[Music]
heart everyone who is successful must
have dreamed of
something all who have died are
equal remember that your children are
not your own but are lent To You by The
Creator one Reign does not make a
crop man's Law changes with his
understanding of man only the laws of
the spirit remain always the
same what the people believe is
[Music]
true you already possess everything
necessary to become
great There Is No Death only a change of
Worlds life is not separate from Death
it only looks that
[Music]
way you can't wake a person who is
pretending to be
[Music]
asleep it is less of a problem to be
poor more than to be
dishonest one finger cannot lift a
pebble Beware of the man who does not
talk and the dog that does not
[Music]
bark all dreams spin out from the same
web old age is not as honorable as death
but most most people want
[Music]
it even a small Mouse has
anger if a man is as wise as a serpent
he can afford to be as harmless as a
dove the rainbow is a sign from him who
is in all
things walk lightly in the spring Mother
Earth is pregnant
when a man moves away from nature his
heart becomes
hard everything that power does it does
in a
circle a brave man dies but once a
coward many
times a man or woman with many children
has many homes
[Music]
seek wisdom not knowledge knowledge is
of the past wisdom is of the
[Music]
future if you see no reason for giving
thanks the fault lies in
[Music]
yourself a good Chief gives he does not
take coyote is always out there waiting
and coyote is always
hungry listening to a liar is like
drinking warm
water every animal knows more than you
do to touch the Earth is to have harmony
with
[Music]
nature when a fox walks lame the old
rabbit jumps
many have fallen with a bottle in their
[Music]
hand a starving man will eat with the
wolf a danger foreseen is half
[Music]
avoided the coward shoots with eyes
shut it is easy to be brave from a
[Music]
distance the bird who has eaten cannot
fly with the bird who is
hungry ask questions from your heart and
you will be answered from your
heart a hungry stomach makes a short
prayer do not wrong or hate your
neighbor for it is not not he that you
wrong but
yourself make my enemy brave and strong
so that if defeated I will not be
ashamed cherish youth but trust old
age sharing and giving are the ways of
[Music]
God we are all one child spinning
through through mother
[Music]
Sky each person is his own
judge we are made from Mother Earth and
we go back to Mother
Earth it is no longer good enough to cry
peace we must act peace live peace and
live in
peace there are many good moccasin
tracks along the trail of a Straight
Arrow a rocky Vineyard does not need a
prayer but a
pickaxe with all things and in all
things we are
relatives the one who tells the stories
rules the
world the Frog does not drink up the p
in which he
lives a people without a history is like
the wind over buffalo
grass the Moon is not shamed by The
Barking of
[Music]
dogs white men have too many
chiefs if a man is to do something more
than human he must have more than human
powers the soul would have no rainbow if
the eye had no
tears wisdom comes only when you stop
looking for it and start living the life
the Creator intended for
you not every sweet root gives birth to
sweet
[Music]
grass take only what you need and leave
the land as you found
it it takes a thousand voices to tell a
single
story don't let yesterday use up too
much of
[Music]
today no River can return to its source
yet all Rivers must have a
[Music]
beginning
listen or your tongue will make you
deaf man has responsibility not
[Music]
power the rain falls on the just and the
unjust each bird loves to hear himself
sing The Way of the troublemaker is
[Music]
thorny God gives to each a
song a man who looks first to a woman's
outer beauty will never know her beauty
Divine for there is dust upon his eyes
and he is
[Music]
blind
a man must make his own
arrows after dark all cats are
leopards when you die you will be spoken
of as those in the sky like the
[Music]
stars